all right my next guest is a New York
Times columnist and MSNBC contributor
please welcome our friend from back in
the studio Bret Stevens is at his home
in New York City how you doing Bret good
to see you there hell I'm perfectly fine
right here in New York good
so you wrote about the city you live in
the city I lived in twice the city I
still love I certainly have a lot of
friends back there my sister's back
there feel for that city the point of
your column this week though was that
the devastation of New York is atypical
from the rest of the country and the
rest of the country should therefore not
have to play by the same rules is that
about right yeah that's exactly yeah I
mean look at Westchester County just
north of the city
it's a commuter County it has suffered
more deaths than the entire state of
Texas NASA or Suffolk County and on Long
Island they've suffered more deaths than
the entire state of California so
obviously the the combination of factors
but especially population density in New
York City makes it just a completely
different situation from the rest of
America and so it means that New York
has to be sort of thought of and treated
differently than say the the middle of
the country or I mean I'm in LA I read
the the in your column that the death
rate is 16 times in New York what it is
in LA per hundred thousand people which
I guess because of density right and we
don't ride subways and we're not in
elevators as much well I mean that's and
the moment you stop to think about it
it's it's obvious right I don't I don't
when I used to go to work I didn't go to
work in a car I jammed into a subway
with a hundred other people or however
many people per car I jammed into
elevators to get to get to my office so
all of that is just completely different
from LA it's as la is the second largest
city in in the country but it's it's
just a very different story and so if
you're treating everyone and kind of
one-size-fits-all approach you're gonna
make some very large mistakes because
it's simply a different type of
situation from from the standpoint of
the spread of disease in one part of the
country then the other to me this kind
of seemed like a fairly obvious not even
a controversial point but not all of my
readers felt the same way no I'm sure
there's a lot of groupthink and I'm glad
you know Tom Friedman was writing about
Sweden as many people are now and I
noticed at the end of the column he felt
the need to say I'm writing about Sweden
not because I'm saying it has the magic
answer but because I think we should
debate all sides of this I'm like yeah
do we really have to say that now but
yes we do that's the atmosphere we're in
and we should debate all sides so let's
talk about Sweden it's the hot new
country for how they're handling it
which is different they let their
they're going for herd immunity which at
the end of the day I think we're gonna
find out you have to have to defeat this
thing anyway I don't know if we have the
time with the state of our economy to
wait for vaccines and all the testing it
would be wonderful if we had a competent
president and a brilliant electorate and
the people were in great physical shape
to begin with and the vaccine was right
around the core we don't have any of
that well that's that's right and the
thinking was well you can sort of stop
the economy for I don't know two or
three weeks and suddenly a miracle is
going to present itself in the form of
an effective therapy or a vaccine and we
can treat and and we could have treated
this episode is kind of an extended
sabbatical or vacation but we not we
might not get a evacs he never minded in
eighteen months it could be many many
years there is only so long you can ask
people effectively not to breathe not to
go to work not to draw a salary without
creating a problem which is vastly
larger even the disease itself and I'm
not some kind of kovat denier I'm not a
booster as you all know for the
administration but we can't simply
our brains hear people say well Sweden
has done much worse than its neighbors
Norway in Finland which is true it's
also done about about the same as
Ireland which is which is in lockdown
and it's much done much better than in
France and Britain so I'm glad the
Swedes are providing us with a model of
an alternative approach to to this
problem and at some point we have to
move from a strategy of trying to
protect everyone bill which I don't
think is going to work it might have
bought us some time but it's not going
to work - looking at vulnerable
populations the elderly people who have
who are immunocompromised have other
health issues and focus our efforts on
them without without wrecking
unbelievable damage on the country in
the process right because I wonder that
if that we've sat home here for two
months as most of the country has and
they say well it might come back in the
fall and it probably will because by
staying home we haven't achieved that
herd immunity so what to me where the
rubber meets the road now is what do
people say about this fall what if it
comes back do you lock down the economy
again I'd love to hear one politician
say no I'm sorry but that's we did it
once and we may have already screwed the
pooch on the economy with that one time
but we just can't do it again we have to
think of something else or try something
else we just have to we have to be
strong well I think that's you know one
of reaction I've had to my column which
kind of staggers me is people say you're
putting the economy over people's lives
and that's that's just false the economy
means food on the table for your family
the economy is essential for human
health and well-being
we're not weighing lives versus the
economy we're wing lives versus lives
one form of hardship against another and
the idea that we're going to repeat this
exercise in November and December as we
move into flu season if in fact this
thing is is seasonal or not we're not
really sure yet
seems to be like a recipe for a
catastrophe that will haunt us for a
century I mean have people looked at 30
billion jobless Americans the figures
that are coming in it's staggering and I
think it should should be frightening to
people who care about public health as
more than just a matter of kovat well I
excuse me if I'm repeating something you
may have said admitted ago because you
went out and out of the sound there for
me because we are of course using
inherent or very moderate no not your
fault you know again I'm not well I'll
just get to the point it was in the
front page of your paper today 30% GDP
contraction is what they're looking for
in the next quarter they just got the
results from this one which isn't as bad
as they said that for this one it's a
piece of cake even though if you like at
this one and normal times you go oh my
god we are we are going into a horrible
recession this is the easy quarter it's
the next one I mean we're looking as you
said about numbers I I don't get it I
think the world has gone mad if they
think that everyone can be out of work
at the same time and yeah we're we
weren't prepared for this to begin with
people don't have that kind of money and
they're not getting it from the
government and and look you know there's
there's no end of blame to be assigned
to the Trump administration to all kinds
of people but you actually eat that that
aside you have to sort of think ahead
and say if now if the Great Depression
is what gave us the rise of fascism and
a certain Chancellor in Germany what is
the next Great Depression going to do to
our to our politics we were already
moving in a populist and neo
authoritarian direction with the economy
was relatively good what happens when
you have tens of millions of people who
are out of work and and and desperate
not just economically but also
politically so people have to start
thinking about the balance of risk
that's that's something no one likes to
contemplate because they say well
if you choose one if you if you balance
it in one way people are going to suffer
and people are going to die and that is
almost certainly true but there are
risks to simply pretending that we can
hold our breath forever and not and not
hurt ourselves right now this is a
strategy out of the Vietnam War we're
trying to destroy the village in order
to save it and I don't remember that
ending very well right I read a headline
in I think it was NBC News it said
starving angry and cannibalistic
America's rats are getting desperate
because there's less food so the and I
thought oh my god this is this could be
a harbinger you know people are going to
get desperate and starving and I hope
not cannibalistic but let me ask you one
question about that and I'll let you go
so we used to argue about the
environment and I never understood how
somebody who I liked so much and who
wrote so many things and not being a
liberal and I'm mostly a liberal I
agreed with but on the environment I
never could quite get you to where I
wanted you to be has this changed your
opinion on that at all on which part of
the environment I'm in fearful that that
we better treat the environment way
better than we have or else we're the
ones who are going to die from it well I
actually believe it or not baby there's
a giant failure of communication on my
part I've always believed that I grew up
in Mexico City where the environment is
pretty pretty horrible and you see the
consequences of that I think we've got
to treat mother nature with a great deal
of respect but I think we're also
learning that productive healthy
economies and robust scientific
establishments are also a big part of
helping ourselves coexist well with with
the environment so look I think this is
going to scramble our politics in a lot
of ways and one thing that I should say
and I think any honest person should say
is that if we all emerge from this
situation with the same convictions that
we've had before it
were just not thinking and so this has
prompted new thinking on my part I'm
sure it has on yours but we need to
maybe move out of all of our respective
ideological boxes because what just
happened was 1929 things have changed
and if you're thinking does it adapt you
have you have problems of your own in
addition to the problems of the world
okay well I appreciate you coming on not
that you really had anywhere else to go
I know it's so easy to get guests these
days hey are you available am i
available of course everyone's available
but you're always a great guest I thank
you I'll see you in the studio soon I
hope thanks they'll be well
you